youssef souidi aujourd'hui on se trouve
pour la suite à la désolation ses
passions étaient donc dans ce conduit et
sept hommes étaient juste là un
finalement il renifle et notre odeur
corporelle sortait un peu le faux vin
c'était en fin de vidéo donc à mon avis
avait un petit peu de transpiration dans
l'histoire donc cet individu appelé
android fils de chien autrement dans
notre langage à nous est juste là bas
voilà il va pas tarder à me repérer je
vais les voir et jeter un oeil et bunge
et diana il mon gars allez hop on
alimente vous allez vous faire mal c'est
toi tu vas me faire mal menteur voilà
une tapis mais des petits coups de pied
à une formation dans le bon coup de pied
va-t-en
qu'est-ce qui se passe ok ça soulève il
ya un trou en dessous en cours l'adorent
ma patience a des limites bah ouais bah
t'as pas sur celle des limites et tu
sais pas souhaité remettre mon gars et
est-ce qu'un jour on va réussir à
s'enfuir de ce [ __ ] de vaisseau allez
on se casse par une balle échelle voilà
on va sortir par là moi je pense que si
on s'en sort et commande sur terre
finalement on va devenir ouvrier ça
c'est clair et net
on fera des travaux de daou offre à des
maisons à la perfection munitions de
pistolets mon appart pistolet ce qui
veut nous voir
voilà la wii oh non non on s'enfuit pas
papa ben bada os
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ça peut faire
mal ça oui c'est un sèche-cheveux
bionique
alors qu'est ce que c'est aux roses non
[Musique]
oh ça fait extrêmement mal un pistolet à
clous allait ouvrir cette porte ouvre
toi
alors ça c'est quoi abbas à un ascenseur
parfait on passe à la suite aller vers
le réacteur centrale c'est quoi le but
l'a déjà allé au réacteur mais c'est
plutôt bien alors ce qui m'aurait dit
aller aux grecs du coin ç'aurait été
moins bien réacteurs centrale par ici
voilà en mai serait ce notre fusil à
pompe
oh oui oh comme ça me fait plaisir bon
enfin à moitié puisque ça veut dire
qu'on va avoir un max déni comme d'hab
mais bon il le petitou sauvegarde qui
nous met bien c'est parti à jacou
lumières s'allument comme ça au fur et à
mesure j'ai l'impression est une
personne très importante dans ce
vaisseau alors finalement je suis qu'un
déchet parmi tant d'autres d'avoir un
android en masse [ __ ] c'est vrai
acteur du vaisseau les gars à ouidah
corsa black pas effectivement sauf cette
histoire va extrêmement mal terminée
maintenant les regardent ils me
regardent et sortent carrément lui
bonjour bah oui tu veux prendre
l'ascenseur je te laisse y aucun
problème encore faut-il que tu sois en
vie pauvre merde voilà biya il nous
reste cuba de revolver de quoi tuer un
androïde virgule dos jamais viendra
d'android dans pourrait le tuer ça y est
on est dans la base du réacteur ou
ouvert la maintenance du réacteur est ce
que la fin du jeu se trouve dans cette
vidéo c'est la question à oui d'accord
ou qui sait y avait un problème ici bas
si pourtant c'est là bas leur voix c'est
détruire le nid a reconnu et de
sauvegarde entre les oeufs etc
on trouve un petit téléphone et ben
surcharger le noyau alpha même dans les
intestins c'est plus propre qui sied sur
les connaît oh il un bruit j'ai
l'impression de me faire agresser par
des racines d'arbres la hâte en ont mais
déjà ce truc avait une voix d'un bébé de
3 ans je refuse de me dire que j'ai été
tué par sa scandaleuse assez ça regardez
il ya une petite main par terre
dégueulasse a cédé bébé alien ils sont
comme ça à la base avant d'évoluer mais
on n'ose pas compte des [ __ ] de bébés
sont les connais allez on active le
conduit à face est parti en europe et
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe ça va
être cool
surcharger le noyau b tu as roma tout
sauvegarde mon gars on a en tout cas
vraiment des aliens la tablette va
regarder qu'en fait j'avais pas un allié
à bord du vaisseau il y avait un nid une
colonie aux saloperies de bébé avec
votre grande que la mapa mais non il
faut rétablir le courant j'obtiens mon
ouïe et ben c'est pas lui qui va nous
aider à rétablir aller tout remonte
aussitôt ben voilà c'est juste la cour a
établi ce petit courant au pas ok tu en
es bon je me cachais retourner dans le
réacteur centrale
oh là là me suis même plus le chemin
bras ah ouais ok ayem petit mais aussi
libéré non paris c'était bon nos ballons
c'est moi une un hall et petit bâtard
saloperies batteur bâtard bâtard bâtard
allez allez ça m'a tendu ce passage de
merde mettait dans leur nid quoi merde
pour faire faut faire un truc là alors
surcharger le noyau alpha est surchargé
siaba et surchargé le noyau bêta c'est
parti on y va à yahr plein d'android
[ __ ] mais c'est une blague c'est cette
blague c'est mike sérieusement allez on
se l'est fait au au bâton mais ça suffit
aulas a one shot en fait ok encore un et
on est bon il est balèze leur pistolet à
clous et black pas c'est plutôt un fusil
à pompe à clous mais bon alors
maintenant on peut parler politique 1 je
pense que c'est le moment donc bien
évidemment c'est tout ce que ce plan va
complètement foiré elle veut faire péter
les réacteurs pour que ça fasse péter le
nie mais au final il n'y a rien du tout
qui va péter ou s'il va péter c'est tout
sauf les aliens c'est la tempête dans ce
vaisseau il saisit l'évacuation du
contour du réacteur allez allez allez
traces traces traça mandat c'est pas le
moment de tomber et de se fouler la
cheville comme dans les films
il saisit un peu j'avais koba ah bah
voilà budget au prix mais ça marchait
c'est parti à l'est on veut du spectacle
s'il vous plaît
on voit rien que nous mijote waouh ça va
péter salle ça va péter ça rien aliens
il a tout fait foirer
il a tout fait foirer et voilà on avait
prédit le vilain un [ __ ] ça marche
il en reste encore dans la station merde
je suis désolé à kindu un [ __ ]
m'attendent ont traversé tout le
vaisseau qui arrivent les cartes aux iem
samuel c'est de passer y aller déjà
oublié allez c'est parti on va devoir
traverser tout le vaisseau mais on fait
on va le connaître par coeur d'un
donneur fabricant de vaisseau maintenant
on connaît tous les plans où j'avoue
j'ai déjà trouvé trois métiers pour un
mandat soit au tour sur terre ça fait
beaucoup
allez là mais c'est comme ça va faire
une grève
ricardo communication voilà pourquoi le
sujet mardi
il est amarré au quai j'arrive ok alors
trouver une ambulance de courte portée
ben j'y vais de ce pas mon ami allons
donc trouvé cette ambulance ripley n'est
pas de nature agressive mais là-bas
laissez moi le temps de dire s'il vous
plaît moi je veux savoir plus sur ces
triplés coësmes pirater la porte est
monté dans la navette attendez attendez
attendez serait ce la fin du jeu à ce
moment j'y crois pas ça surtout depuis
le début par un style pourquoi là ça
marcherait puis ce fut la fin du jeu
c'est d'ailleurs une photo de steak et
toi
oui et toi mon ricardo a fallu poser la
question est pourquoi mais elle s'en
fout elle seule elle se bat aussi ça
marche les gens c'est fantastique je dis
pas que la navette est cassée ou un
problème au décollage en cours
oui oh oui oh oui
l'évasion c'est l'évasion me fait pas le
coup de la lienne était caché sous siège
non c'est bon non y'a pas d'aléa non non
je vous explorez l'amnésie doha si c'est
bon on a réussi dans le [ __ ] de
vaisseau de marleau et mais c'est obligé
quand son fion de l'ancien vaisseau et
en arrivant dans celui-là il a emmené en
haleine avec lui enfin exprès alors
remettre les stèles d'énergie de
l'amnésie doha en ligne et voilà c'est
bon le v6 on retrouve sa jeunesse c'est
comme une crème hydratante mais la
version vaisseau info que jacques le
truc est donc qu'est-ce que ça fait à la
sarre ait vu pour de bon là c'est la
crème anti-âge carrément alors je vous
présenterai option hammam voilà c'est
gratuit il suffit de se mettre ici on a
de la vapeur extrêmement chose qui va
des dates et les ports pour finalement
remettre un petit feu 2 c'est sûr et
certain que marleau objectif les agents
retrouver marc dos ça va je veux juste
rentrer chez eux maintenant
alors au nom mario qu est-ce qu au nom
il est avec les déficits
qu'est ce qu'il fait [ __ ] mais les
bains [ __ ] d'alien il a ramené un bébé
alien dans le vaisseau ce groupe compte
barlow marleau on aura ta peau des
fesses mon gars et je fais comme si tu
regardais ma vidéo alors que non tu es
un personnage de jeu vidéo marley et moi
je suis un jeune schizophrène à marlowe
marleau jeff c'est lui qui a ramené les
aliens sur sébastopol il était parti en
exploration avec son équipe là il ya un
bébé alien qui s'est agrippée à sa botte
il a ramené sa patte sur son vaisseau
final ils sont allés sur sébastopol pour
trouver de l'aide en gros et beau bébé
alien partout bon c'est quand qu'on le
voit la halle et je suis prêt à bien
l'accueillir moi vous en faites pas à
consulter la boîte noire
oui mon gars cet enregistrement est pour
toi ma petite chérie
oui j'espère que tu pourra écouter ça si
le chantre en fait tu vois j'ai eu
quelques ennuis mon vaisseau à imposer
on a eu un accident mon coeur et on a
trouvé une créature extraterrestre
vraiment très dangereuse et détruire le
vaisseau
c'était notre seule chance de l'arrêter
je vais bien je suis coincé sur cette
navette de sauvetage pour un bon bout de
temps encore mais il fallait qu'on
détruise levé 100 il fallait qu'on
détruise le nostromo on ne pouvait pas
prendre le risque de ramener cette chose
avec 97 l'heure je devais tout faire
pour te protéger
ne t'inquiète pas ne t'en fais pas pour
moi je suis très bientôt j'espère je
t'aime aussi maman m'a chargé en émotion
wakim pensée insensible à tout ça barlow
barrette marleau pourquoi tu fais ça
surcharge et leurs affluents
ouais il va péter de vaisseau les
stations d'accord d'accord mais tu as tu
eu personne dans l'histoire et samba sow
des aliens c'est pas con d'à côté ce
qu'il veut faire tuer mais je suis père
dire mais penser au podium elle il va la
[ __ ] et il va l'appeler
oui oui tu l'as tuée gros con haut
j'espère tu l'a vraiment assommés oh non
tu vas cette console allez vas-y
c'est bon c'est fait tu vas vivre mon
amour j'ai plein d'amour dans cette
série ok ça va oh c'est bon il va se
réveiller marleau non c'est bon il est
là je voyais un bout de viande ou de
graisse qui dépasse en mer
je t'aimais dépressive échappez vous on
a beaucoup de courage ou vont s'en fait
pas ok allez allez on court on sait par
où c'est pas moi c'est par la chute soit
pas les dents le feu finalement certains
artifices gratuit là c'est pas mal c'est
la liberté qui s'offre à nous la vraie à
l'étude écoles la pression est au summum
espace trop de trucs dans cet épisode
c'est dingue qu'on a réussi à s'enfuir
ricard nerfs merde tu vas moyens de
contacter le torrent et voilà et [ __ ]
je me retrouve dans ce nouveau dans ce
vaisseau avec un max d'alien oui oui oui
koné du poney du côté d'où vous pouvez
même prendre un petit alien comme ça
fera aller désolation deux places et
blagues ne fait pas ça vraiment
j'insiste j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive
replay n'est pas de nature là mais c'est
dingue j'ai laissé moi lire cette phrase
trouver un moyen de contacter le torrent
mais j'ai un pistolet à clous donc
attention aux quais total entre
roquettes moi j'ai un pistolet à clous
j'ai raté non il a fait un petit tout
comme ça et que sa tête au moment où
j'ai tiré mais bien sûr ques les faire
mon gars ils craignent le feu ces
petites merdes aaa au muscat ça a marché
on est bon on est fort rebond
puisqu'elle atteint mais oui mais
maintenant je suis pas dit que oui ou
non
salut mon [ __ ] heureusement que cet
homme n'avait rien dans le cerveau thi
doan aveuglante comme ça hop dans le
teaser est là enfonce il est où il est
haut au gardien rien du tout j'ai dit
mon tendon ça t'apprendra cadeaux
j'arrive je suis prêt à tuer pour toi
d'ailleurs c'est déjà fait oh il ya un
mec là mais c'est pas ricardo mais si
c'est le cardo comment je fais pour ne
pas te reconnaître mon amour oui les
permissions bloqués oui contourner
apollo ça m'intéresse c'est un abattoir
près des corps ouais j'aime cette idée
on n'a plus qu'à trouver l'observatoire
de sébastopol aulas bitches
j'avais envie de tirer comme ça faisait
longtemps alors on y est est-ce qu avoir
contacté le torrent telle est la
question pardon bâton fois je m'excuse
un simple objet ok ça c'est fait
coordonnées du torrent
oui c'est parti papa papa papa papa il
est temps de se changer à bandar pour
mettre une tenue que même les stars
mettre sur le tapis rouge de cannes
ultra moulant ultra sexy c'est parti
olala ya un max de bruit bitouah oui je
me dépêche me dépêche
effectivement il va pas très bien
sébastopol un j'aime bien voir qu'on en
extérieur comme sa superbe au qui ont
assez proche du soleil donc en plus ça
permet à mandat de prendre quelques
couleurs
c'est parti [ __ ]
maire de touques est actuellement de
paris ok j'y vais retirer le verrou de
l'antenne parabolique atteinte aux
places et à mon équipe comme ça se fait
pas trop c'est bon ça se tourne ça se
tourne et on reprend les coordonnées la
vue qu'à plus vers où tout devrait
parfaitement et des mois vous en supplie
c'est marqué juste à côté
merci beaucoup allez enfin enfin on sort
de cette perte il était temps elle
atteint cette parabole est astronomique
1 est ce que c'est bon est-ce qu'on ait
enfin tirer d'affaires sur l'action
c'est la merde torrent il ya un
organisme alliés victimes mortelles
on a besoin d'une évacuation d'urgence
aux attentes expliqué à l'époque du père
l'aide pour abbas est très utile alors
trouver un moyen d'amarrer le torrent
mais disons mais c'est qu'on se
rapproche de la sortie et serait
quelqu'un d'un sol en si je vous disais
qu'on fera tout ça dans le prochain et
dernier épisode aliens espalion je suis
fier mais bon faut pas trop et bavaud
l'agencé vient enfin de cet
avant-dernier épisode à l'isolation ne
m'en voulez pas vous en faites pas on
sort à la fin de juin et tout ce qui se
passe dans le prochain épisode dimanche
soir soyez au rendez vous bref on se
retrouve dimanche soir j'espère cet
épisode vous a plu n'hésitez pas à aller
mais si c'est le cas et merci d'avoir
regardé on se retrouve très vite pour la
suite car tout le monde
[Musique]
dramatique version